we're talking today about the role that
shaping the future work
we're talking with Professor Scott's
turn the chair of our Sloan schools
technological innovation
entrepreneurship and strategy group and
with Barbara Dyer the president of
Hitachi foundation the foundation works
with entrepreneurs to build both good
companies that are financially
successful as well as ones that provide
good job opportunities can entrepreneurs
build a good job strategy creating good
opportunities for the full workforce in
from the beginning so I think one of the
greatest misconceptions is that being a
good entrepreneur and building a company
that really scales is actually in
opposition to building a company that
creates great jobs in fact I'd claim
that exactly the reverse is true to
attract the really best people to really
create meaningful innovative value for
consumers to really be in a situation
where ultimately you are able to charge
a price well above your cost and create
that kind of value means that you need
to be attracting nurturing investing in
employees in meaningful ways if everyone
who shows up to your company is simply
you all it is about cost well then
there's not much of a company at all
there's not much of an organization
there what we've observed at the nearly
100 companies that we've looked at
across healthcare and manufacturing is
it the businesses that create great
quality jobs don't begin with the
premise that this is a good HR strategy
they start with what is excellence and
they very quickly figure out that the
workforce piece of it is a critical part
of operations they have to invest in
their people and they have to create
systems to provide ongoing support
ongoing learning ongoing incentives so
that their people are really delivering
in the best possible way we hear that
many investors have a mindset that labor
is a cost
minimized and and put a lot of pressure
on entrepreneurs how can we overcome
that resistance we have to do the hard
work of persuading investors that it's
not a choice between lower profits but a
better workforce right versus higher
profits and cheaper workforce instead
the choice is for equally viable
businesses we get to choose the kind of
organizations we built successful
venture capitalists who have built
successful companies they meaningfully
talk about the great organizations
they've built entrepreneurs are
uncomfortable talking to investors about
a workforce strategy they are concerned
that investors will view this as excess
as having too high a burn rate they
don't have fully at their grasp the
economics of it they can't really make
the business case as well as they might
like to as to why it is that building a
strategy like this will end up achieving
the numbers in the next 25 10 years
there is a tendency to expect that at
the startup phase the founders will
certainly work for below market rates
and that the people that are hired will
work for below market rates they'll work
around the clock there should be no
expectation of salary increases or
benefits because the company hasn't
started generating a profit now you're a
scholar you know that the research tells
us that if you build into the DNA of a
company from the very start this kind of
commitment this kind of strategy it'll
be the driving framework for the company
over time and so that's where all the
evidence from other organizations plays
in if you can help them to make that
business case to understand the
potential then there's some hope and so
we have to find ways to deal with that
could you give us an example of an
organization or two that has really
invested in this way take for example BP
BP is an online car marketplace that's
really kind of fixing the lemons problem
for used cars basically right now you
can think of the used-car industry is
definitely not associated with a good
job strategy not even a good service one
of the key choices that alley resident
one of the founders of this firm had to
make was whether or not the technicians
the people who'd be inspecting the cars
was going to be hiring a series of
contractor inspectors or whether or not
he'd be investing in long-term employees
he got different advice from different
investors about that choice he
ultimately decided that the strength and
the quality and the innovations of his
company could best be made by investing
in employees they all those employees
get extensive training they're upping
their skill level they get some equity
in the company and as that company has
grown all of a sudden they are the
single most visible and single most
memorable and single best advocates for
the company as it's scaled across the
United States jessamine Rodriguez who is
the founder of hot bread kitchen started
with a long-term vision the idea was to
enable primarily immigrant but other
women and men who have an ethnic bread
to take that to the market to create
real economic opportunity through baking
bread and to enable them to build their
own businesses around their particular
craft and so hot bread kitchen now very
successful operation in Harlem is
incubating bread businesses throughout
New York and beyond so it's a bakery yes
but it's far more than that and to help
individuals to kind of build math skills
while they're creating breads to build
business skills while they're creating
breads to build marketing
skills while they're creating bread was
a brilliant touch the bakery is a great
example in one place I should clearly
visit how about other examples recently
we were supporting a sector of energy
entrepreneurs looking to address issues
of climate change and one company
rebound is a remarkable refrigeration
company that has the potential of saving
supermarkets enormous amount of money in
refrigeration costs and dramatically
reducing the amount of co2 the founder
of that company is eager to build a
business that is focused on good people
great jobs pathways of upward mobility
it's who he is it's where he wants to
take his company entrepreneurship can be
used to provide good jobs how do we get
this to become the norm people need to
vote with their feet right as you when
you think about joining a company when
you think about as say you're in a big
company thinking about which kind of
companies to partner with when you think
about I even as an investor make sure
you're having that conversation and
understanding as you're selecting among
different groups to work with different
firms to work with even different
portfolio companies to invest in go one
layer beyond the simple value creation
value capture logic and get to the
organization and the team you are more
likely to be investing in a long-term
play that really delivers fundamental
value and really delivers strong returns
if you're investing in the kind of
company that people are going to be
attracted to and allows people to
nurture and grow well Scott I think this
is an important message for
entrepreneurs for investors and for
young people who really do want to build
great companies that address big
problems in society that are successful
and that provide good jobs and career
opportunities to their peers so thank
you very much thank you very much as
well thank you so much thank you for
your time today you're welcome
you